le seul président
monsieur le ministre j'associe mon
collègue Laurence saumon à ma question
il y a trois mois alors que le
vice-président du Sénat Roger carochi
vous interrogez cela apatriement des
femmes et des enfants de djihadiste
vous avez répondu je vous cite en
réalité notre doctrine n'a pas changé
ironie ou mépris en effet depuis 2009
c'était le cas par cas pour les enfants
dans une logique purement humanitaire et
la tolérance zéro pour les femmes et je
ne veux employer le terme rapatriement
car il s'agit de revenante nous
apprenons par la presse que 15 femmes et
32 enfants sont revenus sans compter les
31 femmes et les 67 enfants l'année
dernière
assumez-vous ce changement de troctrice
c'est-à-dire l'abandon du cas par cas et
ses retours massifs comment assurez-vous
la prise en charge de ces enfants par
les services de l'aseu déjà au bord de
la sphyxie comme l'enfermement de ces
femmes dans nos prisons déjà saturées et
qui sont considérés parfois comme des
héroïnes comment pouvez-vous garantir la
sécurité des Français face à ces
personnes qui haïssent toujours la
France
[Applaudissements]